one legendary tv host declined to beat
up adam sandler so another stepped up
for the right price here's what went
down behind the scenes of happy gilmore
though adam sandler's man-child brand of
humor was established with his previous
film billy madison happy gilmore keeps
the laughs while adding plenty of heart
sure he still flies off the handle but
because he's motivated by the desire to
help his grandma and save her home
happy's a more likable protagonist than
billy we're gonna get your house back
that is a promise
it's no surprise that adam sandler would
grow up to make a movie about golf his
dad stanley sandler was a huge fan of
the sport taking adam out on the links
whenever he could plus adam's love for
the classic bill murray golf comedy
caddyshack is well known so a
golf-themed comedy was a no-brainer but
it was one specific day with his dad
that inspired happy gilmore out golfing
with his father in new hampshire teenage
sandler brought along his friend kyle
mcdonough who went on to become a
professional hockey player he was
smacking the golf ball further than
everybody and my father would say man
this kid is incredible he's got he's got
those hockey wrists
just like happy that brute hockey
strength was enough to dominate the game
of golf mcdonough even beat sandler's
dad in an interview on the dan patrick
show adam joked that his father might
have even liked kyle better than him
as happy gilmore's nemesis shooter
mcgavin actor christopher mcdonald did
such a convincing job that he's still
associated with the role to this day so
it might be hard to believe that he
originally turned down the part not just
once but twice in an interview with and
so it begins mcdonald explained his
reasons for saying no he was simply
tired and wanted to see more of his
family but then as he describes it i
played a round of golf in seattle and we
won and that high was something else so
with my golf shoe still on i went in the
locker room called my agent and said is
that golf movie still available because
i just won this tournament and i'm
feeling a little bit
shooter-ish and then after meeting with
adam sandler where the comedian made him
laugh the entire time mcdonald was
convinced and shooter mcgavin was his
before happy gilmore bob barker was
known as the mild-mannered host of the
price is right i bet you got a lot of
that on let's make a deal it's the price
is right happy
oh yeah sorry it happens let's play some
golf
this made his fist fight with happy one
of the most surprising and hilarious
parts of the film you want a piece of me
i don't want a piece of you i want the
whole thing
[Music]
the chemistry between sandler and barker
makes it hard to believe barker was not
the first choice for the cameo on the
dan patrick show adam sandler revealed
that when his writing buddy tim hurlihi
was working on the script ed mcmahon
johnny carson's tonight show sidekick
was his first choice and now ladies and
gentlemen here
but when they reached out to mcmahon the
answer was no sandler's theory i doubt
he got it i think the script was a
little rougher we cursed a little bit
more and then when ed said no we dialed
it down a bit for bob barker
when bob barker was asked to make what
would later become the most popular
cameo in happy gilmore he had already
spent years training with two pros
martial arts expert and actor chuck
norris and the karate champion pat
johnson let's go
you like that old man
the game show host joked that his
experience honing his skills over those
many years is why he accepted the part
in adam sandler's biography barker
explained in 20 years i never won a
fight norris and johnson both beat me up
so when they offered me this script i
said i'll do it because i win the fight
sandler recalled how early in the
morning on the day of filming the
showdown barker was stretching and
getting ready for the fight in the
bitter cold like a boss but barker
actually had other concerns like
catching pneumonia as he puts it next
time i'd like to work inside
now that at the time of this video's
release barker has reached the
impressive age of 98 he may not be able
to appear in a future sequel but as he's
told sandler if it does happen he wants
more money plus a love scene luckily for
the fans a hilarious epic second round
of barker fighting sandler did go down
on comedy central's knight of too many
stars
in the late 90s adam sandler co-wrote
and starred in a string of hits from the
wedding singer to big daddy to the
waterboy but that success sprung from a
difficult time in 1995 after five years
on saturday night live sandler was fired
recently on the howard stern show
sandler described feeling angry and hurt
and recalled commiserating with his
friend comedian chris farley who was
also fired we got
mad together pretended
pretended we weren't sad and pretended
this
was for the best
but sandler's film career was just
beginning a few months before his final
snl performance billy madison was
released to massive success donkey kong
sucks you know something you suck
and sandler followed this up with happy
gilmore which raked in an impressive
41.2 million dollars these victories
allowed sandler and his loyal writing
partner tim hurlihi to establish their
own company in 1999 happy madison
productions hurlihi and sandler have a
long history together writing together
from saturday night live to happy
gilmore to the more recent netflix hit
murder mystery one of the big reasons
the partnership has worked so well for
so long is because they respect each
other's ideas and always give proper
credit in an interview with esquire
hurley he explained snl teaches you to
be very generous with credit adam is
really good about that
even with all of the memorable
characters in happy gilmore the golf pro
chubbs played by carl weathers really
stood out surprisingly weathers was not
the first choice john amos of good times
fame was but this fact was only revealed
in recent years when amos appeared in
uncut gems with adam sandler in an
interview with vulture the directors of
uncut gems the safety brothers revealed
how sandler and herlihy wanted amos for
chubbs and that it was the studio that
decided carl weathers would be the
better choice amos later confirmed this
during an interview with insider
recalling a screen test he did for the
part of chubbs but he's over it saying
it never worked out but no hard feelings
amos went on to say he's never seen
happy gilmore or watched other movies he
didn't get to appear in because to do so
might stir up sad feelings over roles he
missed out on this is a very zen
attitude that we're pretty sure kevin
nealon would approve of
got a harness in the good energy
block out the bad harness energy block
bad
aside from his classic performance as
chubbs and happy gilmore carl weathers
is also well known for his role as
badass colonel al dillon in predator
alongside arnold schwarzenegger in the
film the duo are part of a military team
sent into south america but are caught
unprepared when they encounter an alien
spoilers ahead but weather's character
dylan didn't fare too well in his fight
with the lethal creature a battle which
resulted in the loss of you guessed it
his right arm fast forward to happy
gilmore nearly a decade later and
weather's chubbs also had some terrible
luck with a nasty creature this time it
was an alligator and the animal ended up
taking the hand from his right arm the
same one he lost in predator was this a
nod to fans of the sci-fi action classic
it sure looks like it damned alligator
bit my hand oh my god
bob barker loved his cameo in happy
gilmore but golfer lee trevino
not so much
the pro athlete made a few mainly silent
appearances throughout the film but when
he did speak his lines were memorable
grizzly adams did have a beard
these brief scenes with the golf
champion are great examples of what
gives the movie its wacky charm so you
might be surprised to discover that
trevino didn't actually read the script
before signing on to the project if he
had he later said he wouldn't have
appeared in the film the golfer made his
feelings clear in an interview with cbs
if they were going to use all those foul
words in there i never would have done
it
happy gilmore has many fans including
pro golfers in an interview for the dan
patrick show christopher mcdonald talks
about his experiences golfing with the
pros who love trying the signature happy
swing the actor explained i meet all
these great players they all try that
shot they think it's the funniest thing
in the world you might be surprised to
find out that this odd method is
actually a legal way to swing as
mcdonald said these guys are crushing it
but you know that's what it takes it
takes a good athlete to hit that shot
just tap it in just tap it in give it a
little tapping tap tap tap a roof
fans have been clamoring for a sequel to
happy gilmore for quite some time and
now it looks like they just might get
one in 2021 the comedian posted a video
on twitter performing the signature shot
okay it's been 25 years since i've done
this
let's see what happens
even made a shout out to shooter mcgavin
i'm scared
[Music]
shooter mcgavin this is for you
a few hours later christopher mcdonald
responded with his own tweet nice drive
gilmore
25 years huh
let's see if it's a
shooter's tour
shooting a ball into a jar in what
appears to be his living room mcdonald
adds money shooters still got it a few
days later in an appearance on the dan
patrick show sandler said a sequel would
be amazing when pressed if that meant
happy gilmore 2 was actually
happening the comedian said yes you can
green light this and christopher
mcdonald agreed adding in a later
interview it would be a complete blast
sounds like a hole-in-one to us
[Music]